a comic book bill well it's perfect
I'm going to inject my ideas right into
the thumping heart of America I get a
real artist to draw it properly
she's an Amazon princess that lives on
an island of all women Paradise Island
and a man crash lands on the island yeah
Steve Trevor the spine and she wears a
burlesque outfit well it's athletic and
silver bracelets they deflect bullets
and all her friends and helpers are
sorority girls who have spanking parties
and everybody fights Nazis and rides in
an invisible plane yes all right bill we
love you truly for nobody and I say this
with all the compassion and truth in my
heart
nobody will ever publish this
dr. Marston you are an esteemed
psychologist
with considerable accomplishments most
notably the invention of the
lie-detector test
creator and sole author of the Wonder
Woman comic books
why don't you write Wonder Woman under
your real name I write what I see about
women I know beautiful brilliant
ferocious they have the power within
themselves to create their own destiny
it's powerful about a woman running
around in a bathing suit I think you
long for an unconventional life what we
want can never happen the world can't
stop us
I wonder if
you are the one with a secret identity
[Music]
war violence hatred the path to peace is
not to finance from politics
it is to solve the problems of man's
heart that's why we need Wonder Woman
and never boring
Supreme of the Wonder Woman it's too
wordy why she's called Wonder Woman I
like it
[Music]